So let's go through the list. Definitely irrelevant requirements
cannot lead to missing functionality in the final product, because
irrelevant requirements actually refer to unneeded functionality in the system.
So functionality that is put in the requirements, but it
is not really needed. So we're not going to mark
this one. Indeed, irrelevant requirements can introduce inconsistencies. So they
could be irrelevant requirements that not only are not pertinent
but they are inconsistent with some of the pertinent requirements.
They can also waste project resources, because if we spend time
designing and then implementing the parts of the system that we
refer to these irrelevant requirements, of course, we are wasting project
resources. And I will not mark the last one because there's really
no correlation between any irrelevant requirements and bugs in the software
system. Of course, by implementing the part of the system that refers
to an irrelevant requirement you might introduce a bug. But that's
not necessarily the case, and there really no correlation between the two.